have you ever wondered what a chemist
really does in this series we asked
people with chemistry backgrounds to
share their stories we have people from
all different fields and careers for
example we have an interview of someone
who works in forensics which is closely
related to analytical chemistry we also
have people from the field of science
illustration and medicine since if
you've ever thought about being pre-med
or doing anything else related to
medicine you probably know by now that
you'll be taking a fair number of
chemistry classes we have someone who
works in industry as a researcher
developing new products and we also have
someone who works in who works as a
programmer at Khan Academy actually and
we have a bunch of other interviews for
careers where it was a little harder to
find pictures but they're all really
cool jobs we have fields that are
covered include patent law and science
media which includes things like making
and producing and hosting science TV
shows we have an engineer who was not a
chemistry major but had to take some
chemistry classes and then and ended up
using chemistry in her job we have an
epidemiologist which is a really hard
word to spell me all just
and it's also a really interesting
career and more and we hope to continue
adding to this collection of interviews
over time so please check back but
hopefully you can tell from this list
that all of these people who studied
chemistry are doing a lot of different
things so there's a lot of ways you can
use chemistry as part of your career
after school so we hope you find these
interviews interesting and helpful and
fair figuring out what you might want to
do as a career